by 1935 Chanel joined cert and became
addicted to Morphine which she used on a
daily basis for the rest of her life she
looks pretty good for a a drug addict if
you were to record all of Chanel's
lovers you would need a stenographer
she and patton had this affair no great
secret hello oh my God another one
how many Affairs did you have what up
guys welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification about the way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way in
let's get started so today I'm going to
be reacting to the dark history oh the
dark side of Coco Chanel now I don't
even is Coco Chanel like a fashion brand
all right it's a woman like she's the
founder of the channel brand anyway so I
found out who Coco Chanel is today
um so she started this fashion brand I
guess she's a very successful
entrepreneur and we are going to see
we're gonna see what what her dark side
is she's basically like
um the mother of feminism like she she's
one of the people that are praised oh
really in this space yeah well fashion
is too often considered the exclusive
property of a few Wilson when one hears
the word Chanel one immediately thinks
of a world famous clothing line and
perfume brand however very few people
know about the dark side and sordid
history of the company's founder these
dresses are low-key cute I'd wear them
I'd wear them Coco Chino's list of
friends contacts and lovers was as
varied as it was legendary as were her
actions during World War II who was the
real Coco Chanel how did she amass such
a fortune during World War II and all
others were suffering how did she manage
to escape being a defendant for war
crimes and crimes against humanity I
want to guess she was a [__] I'm just
gonna I just noticed some patterns that
women get a lot of wealth from being a
[__] it's not
operation hello I'm Colin Heaton former
Soldier Marine Corps Scott sniper
history Professor historian and book
author and we will answer these
questions and other issues on this
segment of Forgotten history Gabrielle
Bonner Coco Chanel was born August 19
1883 and sell more France and was a
businesswoman designer spy and Nazi
collaborator at age 12 after her
mother's death Chanel was put in an
orphanage by her father who worked as a
peddler Chanel was raised by nuns who
taught her to be a seamstress her
nickname came from her brief career as a
singer when Chanel performed in
nightclubs she was called Coco as she
began building her brand Chanel knew
that having a great political and Elite
social contacts list the best way to
Fame and Fortune like these are cute I
I'd wear it so she used all of her
skills in and out of the bedroom to
establish these relationships to further
her agenda one of her longtime lovers
was I don't want to say I called it are
there any women that Rose to power that
weren't [__] I guess I don't think
Oprah was a [__] she's pretty powerful
right Oprah wasn't diplomat
Hans Gunther
flag was half English but mother and had
known Chanel many years before the war
long before the war she had well-known
affairs with prominent people as she
climbed the social ladder at age 23 she
was the Mistress of French ex-calvary
officer and textile Heir Etienne Balsan
in 1908 Chanel began an affair with one
of balsan's friends Captain Arthur
Edward boy Coppell which was another
Scandal but she managed to have him buy
her a boutique which enhanced her
business plan she then opened up another
shop in beeritz and needing money and
more contacts she started an affair with
expatriate Aristocrat Grand Duke Dimitri
pavlovich Romanov of Russia she also
delved into the autistic world where she
became very familiar with Pablo Picasso
and other artists however Chanel did not
discriminate when it came to gender to
get what she wanted one of her Intimate
Relationships was with misia ceret a
member of the Bohemian Elite in Paris
and wife of Spanish painter Jose Maria
said by 1935 Chanel joined certain
became addicted to Morphine which she
used on a daily basis for the rest of
her life I gotta say she looks pretty
good for a a drug addict like what is
she like 30 something there you know
what I mean I'm like another high
profile and scandalous Affair began in
1923 with Hugh Richard Arthur Grosvenor
second Duke of Westminster one of the
wealthiest men in the world it would
appear that he funded many of her
business ventures and their fare lasted
10 years and she adopted his virulent
anti-jewish Outlook she also entertained
prime minister Neville Chamberlain
although to what degree is unknown but
it was another political connection
Chanel also was very good friends with
the Future King Edward VII Prince of
Wales who abdicated and his American
consort Wallace Simpson both being
friends with Hitler this relationship
would benefit Coco Chanel later her
friendship even extended to Edward's
younger brother who became King George V
the father of the current Queen
Elizabeth II it was through these
connections that she became friends with
Winston and Clementine Churchill in the
1920s as well as their son Randolph
Churchill and his wife why does
Churchill sound familiar Winston
Churchill did something or wrote
something British prime minister oh yeah
I wouldn't know that
Chanel's methods Pamela Harriman said
quote Coco was not above bed hopping to
further her social connections and had
the Loyalty of a stray cat whatever
suited her purposes she did it vetting
but wait I just want to know like okay
I'm just I'm just trying to understand
these social dynamics so if she's
sleeping with you and then she starts
sleeping with your friend like the first
guy doesn't feel some type of way like
then wouldn't she just be known as like
a [__] like I don't understand how this
I guess men just don't care they'll
still give hoes money I don't know look
at working with the Nazis which
infuriated The Churchill family so well
known were Chanel's escapades according
to s
4 quote if you were to record all of
Chanel's lovers you would need a
stenographer
include shooting rolina Dietrich as her
business took off her clientele list
grew to include the greatest stars of
the day such as Greta Garbo Sarah
Leander and Marlena Dietrich in 1924
Chanel had entered into an agreement
with her part-time business associates
the vertimer family they had a perfumery
and would fund produce and Market Chanel
Number Five perfume in her name in their
Factory her name recognition would sell
it but they would produce it as Chanel
was an investor and not the proprietor
or the Creator she only earned 10
percent while Pierre vertimer earned 70
percent at part owner and marketer he
had filed beta earned 20 in essence the
bear timers were taking all the
Financial Risk but unhappy with the
arrangement Coco Chanel filed a lawsuit
unsuccessfully against the bear timers
and Horrors always Sue they always Sue
that's their go-to always 30
cruising in the court battle Chanel
believed that she had been had but both
she and the court knew that the
bertimers proved that they were using
their own resources and finances to
create and bottle the product then in
June 1940 after the German occupation of
France she saw the opportunity to
denounce the rare timers as Jews this
would allow her to take the company and
pay nothing she petitioned to the Reich
occupational authority to confiscate the
business as it had been quote abandoned
by Jews she filed a claim of Aryan
ownership and it was approved this would
begin her relationship with the Nazi
occupational Authority and lead to her
greatest no loyalty
however in May 1940 as Germany started
to invade France and unknown to Chanel
Pierre vertimer had legally turned
control of perfume's Chanel over to
Felix Emilio a Christian French
businessman and industrialist before the
verteimers left for sanctuary in New
York so legally all money made by the
company was so under the existing
contract at War's end amio returned
parfum's Chanel back to the bear timers
well known in her Social Circles as an
anti-semite and during the German
occupation Chanel resided at the Ritz
hotel which also housed the senior
German occupation staff it was here that
she made romantic and political
connections to further her agenda Chanel
had started collaborating directly with
the Nazi intelligence services to assist
them in locating prominent Jews in
hiding as well as divulging members of
the resistance another long time lover
perhaps the most important where she was
concerned was the aforementioned
Schellenberg who was in charge of the SD
or sister heistes to operations in
France working with Heinrich Mueller of
the Gestapo wow okay this just before
birth control how did this [__] not get
pregnant okay so like I'm just thinking
on my show this is what I'm gonna say
wait first of all I want to Google did
Chanel have kids because my thought is
this no known children so let me get
this straight this [__] had no birth
control no abortion and she figured out
how to be an absolute [__] and not get
pregnant and in 2023 you guys can't do
the same she probably couldn't get
pregnant though no I don't think so I
feel like I feel like they just like
tracked their cycle back then okay wait
wait it was Coco Chanel oh [__] you were
right sort of
uh I was wrong and you were right
because I said there was no abortion and
she did have an abortion which left her
infertile so I was right yeah
Bridge resistance in addition to the SD
Chanel also worked with the Advair
German military intelligence owner
Wilhelm canaris until his arrest Major
General Reinhard Galen took over and
apparently praised her intelligence
gathering methods in suppressing the
resistance in France by using her
business to gather intelligence
unresistance personnel and their
movements there is even discussion after
the war that Chanel may have been
involved in the Betrayal of Jean Mulan
you appointed leader of the French
Resistance Boulan was betrayed and
captured then tortured to death by the
notorious gestapo Chief in Leon Klaus
Barbie and deshays always felt that
Chanel was responsible he was following
mulan's death that the goal appointed to
Shays as the new resistance leader to
coordinate with the Allied OSS and soe
in France according to Pierre de Cheves
Chanel caused the lives of dozens of
resistance operatives as she knew the
wives very well and had their trust this
information she gave to SS Major General
Walter sheldonberg she single-handedly
crippled the resistance effort she was a
traitor and by proxy or murderous end
quote one plan was cooked Up In late
1943 after a meeting with Hitler
Schellenberg Carl wolf Heinrich Himmler
and canaris the mission was codenamed
Operation of modelhood and Schellenberg
was advised to recruit Vera bate
Lombardi says she and Chanel had
according to the adver previously been
lesbian lovers and Lombardi also had
good connections to high-ranking British
politicians according to Wolf quote
Hitler considered another offer to end
the war with the British Empire knowing
that they were also fighting Japan he
thought that it might be worth the
effort so hindler was told to conduct
the operation and himloid chose
Schellenberg but nothing came of it end
quote this mission was for Lombardi to
carry her peace Overture along with a
letter from Chanel to British prime
minister Winston Churchill to end the
war Wolff stated him was reservations
quote there was nothing Himmler and I
did not know about Schellenberg and
although he was considered effective he
was not completely trusted by Heinrich
this was due to his affair with Chanel
and her having long friendships with the
British royal family and even Churchill
himself Chanel did send a message
through channels via Lombardi on her
visit to Madrid which Lombardi believed
was to establish a Chanel Branch there
Lombardi not knowing the real purpose of
the mission handed the letter over to
the British Embassy to be voted to
Churchill but it was never acknowledged
this event was confirmed by interviews
with the aforementioned SS officers
Pamela Harriman as well as Pierre de
chevis who said quote Chanel is a
traitor and she did not conduct herself
out of political ideology she was only
pursuing her own selfish interests at
the expense of her country and the lives
of others only through her British and
American Connections did she Escape
being placed on trial for collaboration
and treason Charles de Gaulle wanted her
arrested Churchill and even Patton
helped to prevent that Chanel was known
by wolf Herriman deshays and SS Major
General Wilhelm munke have had an affair
with the commander of the Paris Garrison
beijer General Dietrich Von schultes it
was said that she was the one person who
convinced bunch of to not obey Hitler's
order and destroy all of Paris
eventually only Churchill's personal
intervention prevented Chanel from being
arrested died and possibly executed as a
Nazi collaborator end quote the most
logical reason for Churchill's support
was that if Chanel were placed on trial
the anti-jewish and anti-degole feelings
held by many in the British government
and even within the royal family would
have been exposed avoiding such an
embarrassment was top priority also
according to it's so crazy how these
people can be so crazy and have these
horrible like paths and nobody cares or
maybe nobody even knows but it's
interesting how people forget but they
also don't in a way you know because you
can look all this stuff up but in the
grand scheme of things people kind of
forget oddly enough all over Europe were
being killed or at the very least having
their heads shaved for collaborating or
sleeping with Germans Chanel strolled
around without a care in the world
everyone knew what she had done but it
just never made the press end quote it
was after she came back under Allied
protection that she met Patton American
Air Force General Curtis E Lemay offered
his insights into Chanel she and patton
had this affair no great secret hello oh
my God another one [__] how many
Affairs did you have by Ike meaning
Eisenhower and Katie summersby we all
just let it go in September 1944 Chanel
was interrogated by the free French
Purge committee The Apparition according
to Chanel's Grandy's Gabrielle Palace
labruni when Chanel returned home she
said quote Churchill had me freed
however Chanel knew that she still
risked retribution under French law or
even out of personal Vengeance and
French resistance leader Pierre de
Cheves was one of those who wanted her
head Coco Chanel then fled to
Switzerland to avoid arrest for
collaboration and treason which could
still have been filed there was no
statute of limitation ironically
apparently supporting her pro-nazi
position after Schellenberg was released
from prison for war crimes in 1951
Chanel provided for him and his family
and covered his Medical Treatments he
was dying of cancer following
shellenberg's death Chanel turned to
Paris to restart her career in fashion
selling licenses and opening stores all
over the world her Empire included
clothing handbags jewelry and of course
perfume then Chanel filed I mean these
are cute these are I would wear a
publicized lawsuit once again claiming
rights of total ownership of perfume
Chanel Chanel hired Renee to Chevron DC
Francis prime minister Pierre Laval's
son-in-law as her lawyer to sue bertimer
due to the possibility that Chanel's
Traders activities would come to light
and embarrass many people from several
Allied Nations secret meetings were held
ultimately after being in some of these
meetings the virtime resem Chanel came
to a mutual accommodation renegotiating
the original 1924 contract on May 17
1947 Chanel received her percentage of
the wartime profits from the sale of
Chanel Number Five her future share
would be two percent of all Chanel
Number Five sales worldwide in addition
Pierre vertimer agreed to pay all of
Chanel's living expenses for the rest of
her life while many people in the
business World embrace her return all
was not well he was reported that she
lived out the rest of her life lonely
and abandoned due to her history as a
collaborator many believed that she
should have been hanged others forgiven
regardless Coco Chanel died on Sunday
January 10 1971 at the Ritz Paris where
she had resided for more than 30 years
she didn't really was that a w do you
think like her life because on one hand
she got out alive I mean she died
everyone dies but like you know but then
she she ends her life hated and it's
kind of a tale you could really tell
with a lot of women today it's like if
you burn all these Bridges by the end of
your life you're not a nice person No
One's Gonna really want to hang out with
you your hotness only lasts for so long
like who who went or who was at her
death bed I don't know but um let me
know what you guys think in the comments
um did you know that about Chanel did
you know who she was
um like the video on your way out guys
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time